[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar lean lab testing quality
attributes of of water for
pharmaceutical production i am sydney
janetta with sievers instruments by suez
and i will be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by suez water technologies and
solutions
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like now to introduce our speakers
we have caitlin vapp the lead product
application specialist for toc and
conductivity
hayden skalsky the lead product
application specialist for bacterial
endotoxins and brianna nunez lead
researcher and product specialist for
microbiology
caitlin hayden and brianna you may now
begin your presentation
hello everyone my name is caitlin vapp
and i'm the lead product application
specialist for life science at sievers
i'm joined by brianna nunez the lead
researcher for microbiology and hayden
skalsky the lead product application
specialist for endotoxin
today we're going to be talking about
testing quality attributes of water for
pharmaceutical production and how
technologies capable of doing so have
evolved to lean out laboratory testing
practices
during this presentation we'll cover
content around quality attributes we'll
first provide an overview of what
quality attributes exist
including conductivity total organic
carbon endotoxin and bio burden we'll
then talk about why and how we test for
those attributes
eventually getting in to how the testing
of those attributes have evolved to
optimize efficiencies we'll then wrap up
with a conclusion and leave time at the
end for any any questions
so let's start with defining
pharmaceutical water quality
the country-specific pharmacopoeia
organizations regulate quality standards
of the pharmaceutical industry the
united states pharmacopoeia among others
require the testing of conductivity
total organic carbon or toc
endotoxin and bioburden as it applies to
water for pharmaceutical production
evaluating the purity of water as a raw
ingredient of pharmaceuticals is one way
pharmaceutical manufacturers build
quality into their processes and it's
going to be the focus of this
presentation
the primary reason pharmacopeia
organizations mandate quality attribute
testing is for risk mitigation purposes
while pharmacopeia is mainly concerned
with patient risk risk to pharmaceutical
manufacturers can be broken down into
three categories
patient
process and business
patient risk being associated with the
efficacy and safety of administered
therapeutics
process risk being associated with
contamination events and business risk
being associated with costs incurred
from potential recalls or out of
specification results
by monitoring quality at various stages
of the process including raw materials
it's easier to mitigate these three
categorical risks
traditional methods for testing have
been laboratory based
the traditional methods were also
coupled with labor-intensive techniques
and slower testing or assay response
times
alternatives
to laboratory based testing are outline
and online testing which begin to lean
out steps of the testing process
outline testing can occur in a direct
environment in which the sample is
pulled for testing
eliminating the need to transfer samples
from a production setting to a
laboratory
online testing is one that occurs in
real time as water passes through an
online instrument eliminating the need
to isolate and transition samples to the
laboratory
as these apply to lean laboratory
practices lab outline and online
instruments can all be considered lean
lab instruments
lean lab is a relative term with
traditional testing methods serving as a
baseline
with that in mind technologies that
emerge to improve testing efficiency and
productivity even if that's a new lab
instrument can be considered a lean lab
testing method
after we talk about some more of the
traditional testing methods we'll
discuss what lean lab instruments
currently exist for conductivity toc
endotoxin and bioburden
so let's start with connectivity and toc
what is conductivity
conductivity is a measure of the ability
to pass an electrical current through a
substance
inorganic chemicals and salts present in
a substance can alter conductivity
readings
as inorganic ions can come in the form
of cations which are ions that carry a
positive charge and anions which are
ions that carry a negative charge
they have the ability to act as a
carrier for electricity which can then
be correlated to a conductivity reading
the amount of dissociated ions present
is a function of ph and temperature
usp monograph 645 requires water of
pharmaceutical grade to fall under 1.3
micro siemens per centimeter at 25
degrees celsius
carbon dioxide readily dissolves in
water and can dissociate into ions these
are known as intrinsic ions while
chloride and ammonia can be indicative
of extraneous ions
both of which can contribute to
conductivity readings
why do we test for conductivity
usp 645 models their 1.3 microsiemens
per centimeter at 25 degrees celsius
limit from the acceptable amount of
carbon dioxide chloride and ammonia ions
present as the these ions can have a
negative effect on the water's chemical
purity and suitability for
pharmaceutical production applications
carbon dioxide can relate to the amount
of total dissolved gas present while
chloride and ammonia can be indicative
of chemical contamination at high enough
levels
fluoride can damage equipment at high
concentrations and both chloride and
ammonia at high enough levels can be
harmful to human health
usp standards fall significantly below
the levels that would be harmful or
toxic to human health but ultimately the
mandated monitoring of conductivity
stems from inorganic ions and salts
posing risk to patient safety
let's move on to total organic carbon or
toc starting with what is toc
from a mathematical perspective toc is
total carbon minus inorganic carbon
toc is an indirect measurement of the
amount of carbon dioxide formed through
an oxidation reaction
this is differentiated from inorganic
carbon as inorganic carbon is all
intrinsic carbon dioxide to the water
while toc comes in the form of organic
carbon molecules that have been oxidized
carbon dioxide content related to toc
can be traced back to the amount of
original organic compounds present
usp monograph 643 is responsible for
regulating toc content in pharmaceutical
water and it's required to fall under
500 parts per billion
why is it important to test for toc
the amount of organics present can be
derived from chemical contamination
or bacterial contamination
sources can include biofilm and
distribution system contamination
toc also has a qualitative relationship
with microbiological activity that can
lead to increased endotoxin and bio
burden as organic compounds act as
nutrient sources for bacteria
between toc byproducts that can impose
danger to human health
and heightened bacterial contamination
that can pose the risk of disease
toc became a mandated quality attribute
now that we better understand what
conductivity and toc are and why we test
for these attributes hayden could you
explain a little bit more about
endotoxin
thanks caitlyn for that wonderful
introduction and for kicking us off
today i'm going to talk about uh how we
currently test for endotoxin
uh what is currently out there for the
techniques for detection of endotoxin
why we test for it and also how we can
lean out the qc lab in terms of
endotoxin testing
so what is endotoxin
endotoxin is a type of pyrogen and is a
component of the exterior cell wall of
grand negative bacteria such as e coli
endotoxin is a lipopolysaccharide
also known as lps
the lps structure consists of a lipid a
portion containing fatty acids
a disaccharide phosphate and core
polysaccharides as well as the o antigen
the lipid a portion of the lps is the
main cause of the molecule's endotoxin
activity
now human immune cells see that lipidate
portion of the lps as bacteria or a
foreign invader and that foreign invader
or that little trigger that the human
cells see from that lipid a portion will
stimulate a response to fight off these
intruders
endotoxin is present in food and water
and pretty much everywhere else so it's
extremely dangerous if it's entered via
the bloodstream or intrathecally which
is the spinal canal route endotoxin can
be introduced a few different ways which
include injectable drugs such as
vaccines
medical devices
surgery or bacterial infection
so why do we test for endotoxin
again endotoxin is ubiquitous in nature
meaning it's pretty much everywhere as
we learned in the last slide
including food and water now if certain
amounts of endotoxin are introduced
into the bloodstream or spinal canal via
a parenteral drug or medical device
we can develop a fever
shock
organ failure or worst case scenario
scenario death
due to the possibility of serious
illness or death all injectable
pharmaceuticals and implantable medical
devices that come into contact with the
bloodstream or spinal canal must be
tested for endotoxins to ensure patient
safety
even after sanitizing and cleaning
objects or equipment the bacteria may be
killed off but endotoxin will remain
behind and be present this is why it's
super imperative to test for endotoxin
throughout the manufacturing process
mostly all parental drug and
manufacturing and medical device
companies will use water for their
products
some of these water uses will include
drug production
so fermentation lysis purification
also known as downstream cell culture
upstream activities
cleaning validation
cleaning of vessels containers
bioreactors glassware
buffer and drug formulation pre-filled
finish
lyophilized drug reconstitution prior to
that drug re uh prior to the drug
administration
medical device manufacturing and medical
device cleaning
all manufacturers of parental drug
products which include intravenous
intramuscular intrathecal
uh and also medical device companies
that make med devices that come into
contact
with blood will test for endotoxin also
veterinary and animal health products
that come into contact with animal blood
will also be testing their products for
endotoxin testing
now that we learned a little bit more
about endotoxin and why we test for it
briana can you tell us a little bit more
about firework
of course thank you so much hayden it
was a really good description of
endotoxin
um i'm going to
get into what is bioburden and why we
test for bioburden
so what is bioburden term bioburden is
commonly used to describe the total
population of viable microorganisms
present on a surface or in a product
viable just meaning living
so a microorganism or a microbe is a
living organism that can be only
observed through a microscope
common microbial contaminants or
bioburden found in pharmaceuticals or
biopharmaceutical production facilities
are often bacteria or fungi
so bacteria or are a single cell
prokaryote that are very adaptable to
all environments they come into contact
with they come in different shapes they
come in different sizes
some are gram positive
some are gram negative and some are
capable of forming spores
fungi is generally broken down into two
groups as a bioburn that's seen in
production facilities and that's molds
and yeast
so a mold has a very fuzzy appearance it
can be orange black green purple and
found in several different types of
shapes a yeast is a type of fungi that
contains a single cell and can cause
infections in individuals who are
compromised immunocompromised
so each step in
each step in the process of production
inside a pharma facility will have
bioburden limits
so a raw material or a starting material
will have different bio burn limits
compared to a final product
so the ability of microbes to survive
and actually thrive in some of these
conditions is generally a thing of
beauty for microbiologists
however the ability of microbes to be
able to do this is incredibly
detrimental to production facilities
so the question is why do we care about
bioburden and why do we test for
bioburden so in january of 2012 the
american pharmaceutical review published
an article detailing recalls involving
microbial contamination
of the 103 cases presented 34 of which
were caused by berkuldarius sepatia sir
calderia sepatia or berkuldarius sepatia
complex is a gram-negative bacteria that
tends to mutate and adapt very quickly
to its environment even in environments
that are pretty nutrient deprived
sepa can metabolize organic material
present in organic or excuse me in
aquatic environments such as ultrapure
water loops
sepa can cause very serious respiratory
infections in individuals who are
immunocompromised it's
known to be an opportunistic pathogen
that can cause morbidity and mortality
so one of the reasons we test for
bioburden is to ensure the health of
consumers
bioburden testing is also used in the
manufacturing process as a monitor so
sampling and testing will occur
throughout the process to assess the
quantity of bio burden presence starting
in
raw materials moving towards in-process
materials and intermediate products and
also the final product
so as an example
if a raw material or a starting material
was used and it was contaminated
uh the contamination would follow all
the way through so your final product
would also have the same bioburn
contaminants that were originally in
that
starting material
so factors that can influence bioburden
levels are generally broken down into
three things three different categories
there is equipment environment and also
product so is the environment that
you're working in disinfected properly
and regularly
is the hvac system maintained or is it
blowing uh microbes all over your
workstation
is the equipment used in the production
maintenance and regular maintenance
regularly and then once a product is
produced is that product being stored
correctly
so all of these
different things can influence bio
burden levels in a production facility
i'm going to hand this back off to
caitlin and she is going to talk about
how we test for toc and conductivity
thanks bri and hayden for those
explanations on bioburden and endotoxin
as brie mentioned we're now going to
shift gears and get into conductivity
and toc specifically how we test for
these quality attributes
so starting with conductivity
conductivity is the inverse of
resistance and resistance is the
opposition of electrical current it can
be correlated to the amount of voltage
applied over the current which is the
movement of positive or negative
electric particles
with resistivity conductivity can be
calculated
to measure for resistivity and correlate
to conductivity instruments typically
operate off of two electrodes with a
voltage applied between them the drop in
voltage caused by resistance can then be
used to calculate conductivity within an
algorithm intrinsic to the instrument
moving on to toc
how do we test for total organic carbon
all instruments that quantify toc have a
few fundamental properties
including they oxidize organic compounds
to carbon dioxide
the mechanism in which they do this
might differ though it can include uv
oxidation combustion or supercritical
water oxidation
once the organic compounds have been
oxidized to correlate to the total
organic carbon content
the second fundamental quality is that
instruments measure that resultant
carbon dioxide
again the mechanism in which they do
this might differ though so there's
direct conductometric membrane
conductometric or non-dispersive
infrared sensor technology or ndir
technology
with this inorganic carbon
can either then be measured or it can be
a value that's factored into the final
toc calculation through an insta
instrument algorithm that has the
ability to predict the amount of
inorganic carbon present
what's important to note to maintain
compliance is that carbon must be
differentiated and detected according to
usp643
this means number one you must
differentiate between inorganic carbon
and organic carbon and number two
carbon and only carbon must be the
species detected so the analyzer must be
clear of any sort of in or excuse me
ionic interference
this is ultimately what differentiates
membrane conductometric technology from
direct conductometric technology
in the diagram to the left the animation
is a depiction of direct conductometric
technology and the right is membrane
conductometric
membrane conductometric toc analyzers
have the ability to differentiate
between inorganic carbon and total
organic carbon while also measuring only
carbon with a selectively permeable
membrane to filter out any interfering
ions that could cause over an under
reporting that's commonly experienced
with direct conductometric instruments
so while direct conductometric toc
technologies may be beneficial for
process monitoring
it's recommended to pursue membrane
conductometric technologies for process
control and release applications since
they're in compliance with usp643
so now that we've gone through how to
test for connectivity in toc hayden can
you share a little bit more about how we
test for endotoxins
thank you caitlyn so i will go ahead and
discuss how we
test for endotoxins currently in the
industry
so how do we test for endotoxin
bacterial endotoxin testing also known
as bet
is an assay for measuring active
endotoxin in water and products by
combining a sample with limitless
amoebocyte lysate also known as lel
reagent and measuring the resulting
proportional reaction
this leo reagent contains an aqueous
extract of circulating blood cells also
known as amidocytes from the atlantic
horseshoe crab
here in north america
so there are a few ways these lil tests
are ran
which include
gel plot technique two and two
photometric techniques called kinetic
turbinometric
and kinetic chromogenic which we will
discuss in a few slides
the leo reagent
is derived from the horseshoe crab's
blood so the leo reagent comes from the
atlantic horseshoe crab which is
limitless polyphemus
the amoebocytes are the blood cells and
the lysate is the cellular extract that
is used for endotoxin testing
the enzymes extracted from the blood
trigger a reaction in the presence of
endotoxins the blood clotting system
contains a cascade of three inactive
enzymes in a claddable protein called
coagulation
the reaction cascade ultimately ends in
a gel
turbidity or a color change depending on
the method chosen
so the common means for endotoxins
testing today again there are three
methods which are usp85 can pendil
uh the first we see here is gel clot so
this is going to be a qualitative and
subjective method this gives you a pass
fail test or endotoxin is present and of
toxin is not present you're looking for
a formation of a gel in a test tube so
your sample and le reagent are added to
a test tube which is then incubated in a
heat block for an hour
at 37 degrees celsius and at the end of
the hour the analyst will invert that
tube upside down and if it clots it
means it's a positive or endotoxin is
present and if it does not clot it means
it is a negative
kinetic chromogenic which is also known
as kca that is a photometric technique
um
it's quantitative so it gives you an
actual result
and this method measures endotoxin over
time for the appearance of a yellow
color
now it uh we have a colorless
chromogenic substrate that is added to
the ldl reagent which causes the yellow
color to develop after the cleavage of a
chromophore called pna or uh paranitra
aniline
so the more color that is released in
the solution with your sample that means
the more endotoxin is present
and lastly we have kinetic terpenometric
or kta
this is another quantitative kinetic
method that measures an increase in
turbidity or the time taken to reach a
particular level level of turbidity also
known as onset time
the onset time of turbidity is inversely
related to the amount of endotoxin in a
sample
now that we learned a little bit about
how we currently test for endotoxins in
the industry
i'll pass it over to brianna and she can
explain how we
currently test for bioburden
thank you very much hayden
um i'm gonna get into how we test some
bio burden uh bioburn testing as a whole
is kind of old
um it basically involves growing
microbes on an auger plate waiting for
the auger plate to show colonies and
then counting those visible colonies
so the u.s european and japanese
pharmacopoeia have all been harmonized
to define bioburden testing
to actually get a result for bioburn
testing you
take the total microbial count which
refers to your bacteria you add it to
your total yeast and molds count to
receive your total viable count
so the different populations of
organisms are assayed differently mainly
because yeast and moles require
different nutrients than bacteria
they'll often require different
incubation times they'll require
different incubation temperatures so
separate assays occur to assess the
entire population
the three harmonized pharmacopeias have
all listed three different methods to
determine the amount of bioburn present
in a sample so the first test method is
membrane filtration
membrane filtration is the most
preferred because it's the most accurate
and what happens with that is when there
is a sample passed through a 0.45 micron
filter or less
the bioburden is collected on the top of
that filter and then the filter is then
transferred to an auger plate the auger
plate is put into an incubator and at
the end of incubation period colonies
are counted and reported
so there's two different types of direct
plating methods and of the direct
plating methods the pore plate and
there's poor plate and spread plate uh
pour plate is the most preferred of the
two because it has greater accuracy
so a pour plate method uses one ml of
test fluid and about 15 to 20
milliliters of a liquid
auger media
both the test fluid and
the
auger media are mixed together the media
is allowed to solidify
and then it goes into the incubator
spread plate method uses between 50 and
500 microliters of a test fluid the test
fluid is as added to the top of an auger
plate and then it is spread around on
top of the auger plate
most probable number
is another test method but it is the
least preferred because it is the least
accurate to test for bioburden
it's a statistical method which uses
an estimate
or excuse me an estimation of viable
organisms present in a sample so the
test method involves taking the original
solution
and
dividing it in uh two different
magnitudes orders of magnitudes into
different culture broths the culture
broth is then assessed for the presence
or absence of bio burden
um generally bioburden is reported as
cfu per milliliter which means colony
forming unit per milliliter or colony
forming unit
per gram depending on what type of
product was used
so i'm going to pass this right on back
over to caitlin and we can start talking
about how we can lean out our laboratory
thanks for sharing those interesting
methods for testing endotoxin and
bioburden hayden brie
now that we understand traditional
methods for quality attribute testing
let's transition to how quality
attribute testing has evolved to
incorporate these lean lab techniques
and again we'll start with conductivity
and toc
so real-time testing is an application
that's made headway in recent years but
was originally established in 2010
the astm guidance document e2656
to understand what real-time testing is
we need to delineate between three ways
in which online instruments can be used
one process monitoring two process
control and three process release
rtt or real-time testing is the practice
of using online instruments for all
three applications
this requires additional validation but
that inherently improves confidence in
all three ways to leverage online
instruments beyond just real-time
testing's ability to optimize
efficiencies
this is effectively a road map to
integrating rtt into everyday practices
for pharmaceutical manufacturers
with five phases broken down into subset
elements associated with each phase rtt
requires
one that end users scope the project and
organize timelines around project phases
two perform a risk assessment with the
intent of choosing a technology and
placing the technology on the water
system
three implementing with a series of
method and process validation steps
four
data reporting and handling tools
and five keeping up with annual
maintenance and redundancy of the
instrument
ultimately through implementing rtt you
will have the ability to evaluate and
ensure quality in real time through
trending capabilities seen in the
graphic below
rtt implementation also provides an
opportunity to expand your process
analytical technology portfolio to drive
progress for the fda's pat initiative
and with rtt
you will have built process monitoring
control and understanding
all while being able to release water
into production in real time
with that i'll transition it to hayden
to learn a little bit more about lean
lab practices for endotoxin
thank you caitlyn
so
how can we lean out the lab with regards
to endotoxin testing we can do that by
introducing microfluidic technology that
helps automate the bet assay while
remaining fully compliant with the
compendia
microfluidic technology that uses a
microplate with embedded reference
standard endotoxin or rsc with a
standard curve range of 50 eu per ml
down to .005
and positive product controls with every
sample will drastically decrease the
potential for human error by minimizing
that hands-on time
there are several benefits of
microfluidic testing and i will talk
about a few of those here with the
microplate that we see
so a few benefits will include
quick and short setup time so about five
to ten minutes set up time to load the
microplate with 21 samples
we have about 89 to 90 percent fewer
pipetting steps than your traditional 96
volt plate assay so it goes from around
or 242 pipetting steps down to less than
30.
we have a 90 reduction in leo reagent so
we have sustainability in the back of
our minds we take one milliliter of leo
reagent for this microplate
and that can test up to 21 samples where
a traditional 96 well plate you will
need around 10 milliliters of la reagent
we automated the creation and loading of
the standard curve so we have that
standard curve already embedded on the
plate
and we automated the loading of positive
product controls and all of your ppcs
are already on the plate as well
on top of having microfluidic technology
for bet here are a few few more ways to
lean out the lab receivers eclipse
endotoxin platform
there is a client server installation so
endotoxin data can be reviewed and
signed off remotely with the client
server feature minimizing the need to
physically be in the lab so you
can have less footprint in the lab in
terms of employees
and then we have the other reduced
footprint in the lab so the endotoxin
analyzer itself is lighter and smaller
than traditional endotoxin analyzers for
kinetic chromogenic units so you will
have more bench space to do other
activities
and then we're going to have a reduced
cold room storage and increased
sustainability now eclipse microplates
can be stored at room temperature uh we
have stability currently up to 25 months
so there's no need to store plates in
the two to eight fridge and taking up
all that space
and also again the eclipse uses one mil
of leo reagent per plate so we're going
to have a reduced number of reagents
needed to be stored in that two day
degrees celsius for testing
now that we learned a little bit more
about the lean lab in terms of endotoxin
testing i will pass it over to rihanna
thank you hayden and caitlyn for getting
into some ways we can lean out the lab
and different processes to make it a
little easier um i'm going to talk about
how we can lean out the laboratory for
biobird testing
so new technology is slowly starting to
evolve away from traditional plate
methods
so traditional plate methods for
bioburden detection
is accurate but depending on the
organism
it takes days or weeks
to get a result the test method can also
be pretty labor-intensive so it requires
people going out to sample people in the
laboratory to actually sample and count
plates
um so there's a new rise and a new
interest in rmms which are rapid
microbial detection methods
so rapid microbial detection methods are
technologies that allow the user to get
a microbiology result faster compared to
two traditional culture plate methods
there are three different categories of
rmms that include qualitative
quantitative and identification methods
so if the user receives a presence or
absence that would be considered a
qualitative rapid method
if a user receives a specific genus or a
specific species of the organism found
in that sample that would be considered
an identification method and if the user
receives a result at the
numerical result at the end of their
test for the amount of bioburden found
in that sample that would be
quantitative method
so inside of these three different
scientific principles are different
methods
that
the industry uses to determine bioburden
so it's one of these includes
growth-based methods a growth-based
method descri excuse me decreases the
time in which we can detect a growing
micro organism
so some of these test methods include
detecting carbon dioxide or
changes in pressure
during microbial respiration
microorganisms consume oxygen and
produce co2 so if a microorganism is
respiring inside of a closed container
there's often going to be changes in
pressure that will result
viability based technologies are now
pretty common in the industry and that's
because they can differentiate between a
living viable cell and a dead cell
so flow cytometry and solid phase
cytometry are both commonly used in
conjunction with those viability stains
or labels
individual particles
are passed
through a laser beam and they're able to
be counted with flow cytometry while
solid phase cytometry captures microbes
on a solid surface and then they are
labeled with viability stains
cellular component based
test methods rely on cellular markers or
probes that are specific to that
microbial target site so in examples
would include atp bioluminescence and
also the use of mass effect for
microbial identification
viability stains work very quickly to
label and target organisms making
results available within hours or even
minutes so siever's solution to rapid
micro includes viability stains in
combination with ultra-sensitive flow
cytometers
ultra-sensitive flow cytometers are
accurate down to a single cell or
particle and can return results faster
due to the binding efficiency of dyes
and stains used
the
number one advantage to using an rmm to
lean out your laboratory process is you
get faster results so current planing
methods are accurate but they take a
long time for results
rmms can reduce product release times so
instead of waiting for test results a
product can be released to market much
faster
by monitoring the production process and
receiving faster results a production
site can implement corrective actions
sooner and improve the quality and
safety of their products
thanks bree and hayden it sounds like
there are incredibly innovative lean
laboratory technologies that exist for
both endotoxin and bioburden
as pharmaceutical manufacturers strive
to decrease the time to market for
life-saving therapeutics traditional
quality control practices can become a
limiting factor
therefore by adopting lean laboratory
techniques and instrumentation
pharmaceutical manufacturers can improve
their efficiency and productivity with
real or near-time results and decrease
the quality staff's workload
all while maintaining compliance
with faster time to results
the ability to control the process
becomes much easier with direct access
to data that's reflective of present
time points
this improves the capability of ensuring
consistent water quality for release
into pharmaceutical production
so that brings us to the end of our
presentation if there are any questions
on the content covered we're happy to
field those at this time
thank you
thank you
thank you caitlyn hayden and brianna for
your informative presentation
we will now go ahead and start the q a
portion of the webinar as a reminder if
you have a question you'd like to ask
one of the speakers from today please do
so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left side of your
screen we will answer as many questions
as we have time for
so let's go ahead and get started
our first question
is directed towards hayden
when it comes to testing for endotoxin
what about the dialysis water for
hemodialysis patients
uh so
the answer is yes you should be testing
dialysis water for hemodialysis since
the dialysis water will be
helping to filter and clean your blood
so we want to make sure that the water
we are using that is super clean
um it can cause life-threatening issues
if the treatment water is contaminated
so
clean dialysis water
is crucial and testing for endotoxins
for that is essential to
patient safety
thank you
brianna this next question is for you
what applications benefit the most from
a rapid bioburden monitoring method
uh great question so end users have
stated that the most valuable
application applications is at line
monitoring of drug substances and also
drug products
that's followed by water monitoring and
also environmental monitoring and
another application of interest is
definitely cleaning validation
great thank you
caitlyn we'll head to you next
what is the difference between online
monitoring of toc and rtt
that's a really good question um the
main difference is an extra validation
component so
as mentioned in the presentation that
implementation phase has a series of
method and process validation steps
the method validation steps are standard
between online monitoring instruments
and rtt capable instruments that is your
standard instrument qualification
operational qualification and
performance qualification packages
when trying to transition from the
ability to monitor and control with an
online instrument to um real-time test
and release with an online instrument
there are additional process validation
steps that are required um for for
additional confidence essentially in
that instrument and what those include
is a method transfer phase between the
lab-based instrument and the online
based instrument
and then a method comparability study
where you're evaluating the the efficacy
of the online instrument against the
laboratory based instrument and then
also a point of use comparability study
where you're evaluating the quality of
water at some of your most critical
points of use against the quality of
water at that instrument that's
permanently installed and being used for
release
so the the final answer there is that
those additional validation steps are
really what differentiate your ability
to monitor versus release water with an
online instrument
thank you for that description that's a
lot more helpful
brianna will go back to you
what is the recommended implementation
of online bio burden systems on water
loops
so an online water
online bio board and analyzer will be
typically deployed at the return leg of
the water loop
the return leg of the water loop is
known as your ccp or your critical
control point
and your ccp is generally indicative of
the overall health
of the system that you have
thank you
hayden uh i believe this is in reference
to the sievers eclipse can i use my
current lysate with your system
great question the answer to that is yes
so
the eclipse platform uses commercially
available kinetic chromogenic leo
reagent
so
which means that if you are running that
technique today you will be able to
continue using reagents from your
current supplier
so it is available to use
from any uh lel reagent provider that's
fda licensed today
great thank you
we'll go ahead and keep going with you
hayden this one ties into the same thing
how do you validate water samples with
the sievers eclipse
uh so this
uh validation process especially for
water is super easy since water is
mainly tested at a one-to-one dilution
or neat undiluted um you won't have to
make any dilutions so
you can basically just take all of your
water samples and test them on the
eclipse and you can do a simple
compar comparability study to ensure
that your water samples are going to be
compatible with the sievers eclipse so
it is a pretty easy straightforward
process for water
thank you
and just a reminder to continue
submitting your questions um we still
have a few more here but just to get
those in if you have any
coming to you
i'll go ahead and go to caitlin
what should i consider to complete a
failure failure mode and effects
analysis
great question because this is a really
important factor
when implementing real-time testing so
when you're considering a failure mode
and effects analysis or an fmea in the
context of real-time testing
what that is used to inform is where you
end up placing the instrument of record
the online instrument
and also which critical points of use
exist that should be tested against the
water quality at the location of the
instrument of record
so with that being said two main factors
should likely be considered in the
process of completing an fmea
and that's one where along a water loop
is representative of the quality of
water
at every section of the loop
and then two which points of use are
most critical to either the process or
the final drug product
so when you're considering where to
place the instrument normally the
resultant of an fmea
directs you to place it at the return to
tank on a water loop because in theory
the water is passed through
every section of the loop in which it
may have come in contact with something
that would have contaminated it
so it should be indicative of the
quality at every section along the water
loop
and then ultimately it's up to customers
to determine um which points of use are
most critical to the process and drug
product
whether that means a point of use that's
commonly used for manufacturing process
a point of use that's being used to
dilute final drug product um whatever
that might mean for you um there's a
guidance document iec
60812 that can help you
or guide you through the process of
completing an fmea
thank you that was very helpful
description
we'll go ahead and stick with you
caitlin
can i do rtt with my existing online toc
sensors
good question so as we discussed a
little bit in the presentation there's
different mechanisms in which toc
instruments measure toc
so toc sensors are normally referring to
that direct conductometric method while
toc analyzers typically refer to
membrane conductometric
so with that in mind toc sensors as we
had chatted about experience over and
under reporting from ionic interference
and also don't have the ability to
differentiate between inorganic carbon
and total organic carbon other than the
use of an algorithm
so it means that toc sensors um you know
struggle with the usp643 compliance
and then from an rtt perspective the
guidance document that we had referred
to astm e
2656
requires that online analyzers should
perform equivalent or better to that
than the laboratory instrument so what
that means is that the online analyzer
must read lower than a measurement from
the laboratory instrument at the same
time point in which that online
instrument is reading to where you grab
or isolate a sample
so that's typically a fairly easy
standard to pass given that there's
total organic carbon intrinsic to the
atmosphere which can contaminate those
laboratory samples as you isolate them
but given the potential for over and
under reporting with sensors it may be
more difficult to meet this criteria
so with those factors in mind it's not
recommended to pursue rtt with existing
toc sensors
while they're great for monitoring and
control purposes to maintain a pulse on
the water quality
when it comes to leveraging an online
instrument as the instrument of record
for release
analyzers will provide the necessary
confidence in doing so
great thanks for that and for
informative response that was very
detailed
brianna we'll go to you are rapid
bioburden methods validated and accepted
by regulatory agencies
great question uh so yes some rapid bio
burden methods have been validated for
specific applications by end users
and they are generally deployed as a
monitoring method in conjunction with
compendial testing
so
the reason why
we still do compendial testing is this
allows for the accumulation of data
and results and the ability to
compare correlation
and then at the very end have a decent
amount of data
to have new acceptance criteria
awesome thank you
we are down to our last question so if
you have any that you would like to ask
please go ahead and submit them now as
we do still have a little bit of time
left and we'll make sure to get those
covered
hayden this last question is for you
how much sample volume and how much lal
reagent volume is needed for each sample
replicate with the sievers eclipse
that's a great question so
every sample you pipet onto the eclipse
microplate you only need a pipette one
time and that amount of sample you need
is 55 microliters so that 55 microliters
is going to split into four replicates
two replicates will be your single uh
your sample
and the other two uh replicates will be
your sample with a positive product
control
the amount of lel reagent you need
for the full microplate is just one
milliliter and you pipet that one time
at the end and what that's gonna do is
it's gonna distribute equally to all
your samples um in an optical well and
take your reading over time for that
color change
wrap up the presentation for today if
you do have a question after the
presentation the speaker's contact
information is on the screen you can
also submit it in the on-demand portion
of the webinar
thank you caitlin hayden and brianna for
your time today and your presentation we
would also like to thank lab roots for
hosting
before we go i'd also like to thank our
audience for joining us today and for
the interesting questions
any questions that we did not have time
to address today or those submitted
during the on-demand period though they
will be addressed by the speakers via
the contact information you provided at
the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye
you